hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell with ET on
TV I am back on the DWTS dance floor and
I miss it you guys are doing great both
stunning in white tonight I see that
there was another couple in white
tonight with Cody and Whitney was that
plan did you guys know that was gonna
happen
you know what him and I were together
before we both have young fans I think
they're trying to hype up us going kinda
against each other at this point it's
early in the competition we're all
friends I mean he's my homie if we both
continued along yeah I can see that well
cariann made a comment about you being
inducted into the the sexy Hall of Fame
can we see the ABS can we see the app
again because I know America just saw
them a bunch but bump and there they are
again
and they are not spray-painted on I
believe in health and I want to promote
that and so really it's just it's
consistency it's being in the gym or
doing whatever physical act if you like
and eating well to eat healthy but doing
it for a long period of time that's all
it is you know we're both very creative
people and you know she she kind of like
helps me keep a traditional - you know
what I mean so I try to bring my own
flavor and she she's you know really
great about letting me incorporate it
but you know I'm really trying to work
on my technique it's tough because
that's been a you know come in from the
judges just making sure you know really
get like the basics down what do you
think it is that separates you guys from
the rest of this competition
um you know together what kind of the
youngest couple that's ever been on the
show
so you know we really trying to bring
like a young fresh you know just like a
new perspective to it all
I can't even put into words how much I'm
enjoying it you know he's so impressive
on and off the floor so you know I just
feel so lucky and you got a nine from
lend that is the hardest man to get a
score from how does that feel feels
great
we're hoping for more
it's not easy what we're doing as you
know it is very difficult and you need
someone that's patient but you know has
a good technique and has good ideas more
importantly for choreography and for
character and I'm really been counting
on that it seems like he has some
natural ability at movement and I mean
even in when it comes to you guys having
to remain attached to the pelvis he was
just moving fluidly with you what is it
about his skating background that you
think really translates to the dance
floor I will to be honest it's amazing
that you say that because at the start
of the week that wasn't the case you
know it's just that he worked his butt
off on that it's being an Olympian
though he's he's got to know the meaning
of hard work oh yeah I mean he's harder
on him than I am you know it's and
that's a wonderful thing too I know that
he's never gonna stop until it's right
and until he's happy with it so as a
teacher as a coach that's just such an
amazing student to have
you